and it is for this reason that it does not
collected the
corresponding to the month of
January 2 024
retirees and pensioners
available today
on the official ISSSTE website
proof of payment
corresponding to inflation for the month
February 2024
as every year this is
one of the most
expected by you
because they get the increase
to its annual championship
and also the payment of
corresponding to
as of January 2024
in previous videos you have already
Promotion of knowledge
that the increase
in the vast majority of pensioners and
ISSSTE retirees would be 4.66%.
you have to bring out your
percentage and review
that have
correctly increased
on
should also review
who have paid the fee
for the month of January
but like every year,
what happens
with those who win the top
or's maximum?
i.e.
the 10 units of measurement and
update
in the previous videos they were told
that the 2024 ceiling of the
pensions would be $32,571.00 pesos.
and the 2,023 ceiling amounted to
$31,122.00 pesos
what about those who win this
quantity
well usually
ISSSTE never pays them the
for the month of January and is
which generates a dissatisfaction there
of all those retirees and
ISSSTE pensioners
that year after year
have never received or
including
some receive only
cents in this concept
and today we are going to explain
why they do not receive payment from the
as you know
ISSSTE eh pays the every year.
retirees and pensioners or pay the
continues
eh through Big data and it is by
that the
payments
corresponding to
in every month of the year in which we
we find
but specifically in the month of
February 2 024
like no retiree
so established by law and also by the
jurisprudence
which issued the supreme court of
justice of the nation
who cannot win more than 10
units
measurement and updating
on the assumption that
win the maximum or the ceiling of
perfection
Big data
has already pointed out that no one
will be able to earn more than that
quantity and therefore
do not pay them the
and this will continue to happen year
with year
what everyone can do
you who are in
this assumption
the most common and the simplest
is to submit a letter
to its sub-delegation of
performance
where they request payment of the
if you win the
you won the top during the year
of 2 023 and you also win the
ceiling in 2024
there is a difference of 1,449
pesos that the ISSSTE does not
would be paying
corresponding to
as of January 2,
ISSSTE is located
obliged to answer the letter
that present to you
and based on the response
you will be able to carry out the procedure to
recover the
corresponding to
to the month of January
if you want more information
contact us